the second episode of Picard on CBS all
access dropped a few truth bombs about
captain jean-luc Picard's health some
secret Romulan shenanigans and just
exactly what happened during the great
synthetic revolt that shattered the
Federation here are a few things you
might not have noticed between the lines
maps and legends begins on that fateful
day in 2385
when the synthetic workers stationed at
the Utopia Planitia shipyards on Mars
rose up against their flesh-and-blood
coworkers
killing them and destroying the site so
entirely that it's still burning 14
years later but before the day starts
going very very badly we get several
shots of business as usual in the
shipyards complete with a close-up of
what kind of looks like an Argo type
shuttlecraft the Argo was first seen in
Star Trek nemesis when Picard Worf and
data flew the shuttlecraft from the
enterprise-e to the surface of the
planet Caloris 3 where they recover the
Android b4 who we've already seen in
Picard's first episode the shuttlecraft
calls back to an extremely significant
event in the lore of Picard tying in to
the show's certain mystery of datas
involvement in the creation of dodge and
so G April 5th is a very significant day
in Star Trek history established in 2063
it commemorates both the first
successful human warp flight and the
first interspecies contact between
humans and Vulcans as shown in Star Trek
first contact first contact day has long
been established as an annual holiday in
the world of Star Trek in Star Trek
Voyager we even got to see a first
contact Day celebration complete with
warp engine creator Zefram Cochrane's
favorite food and the ship's Vulcan
science officer reciting the Vulcans
initial greeting to the people of Earth
live long and prosper
Captain Janeway also mentioned that as a
child she always got the day off from
school in 2385 though the workers at
Utopia Planitia complained that they
still have to work on the holiday which
they're not happy about having the
attack on Mars take place on April 5th
marks a sharp parallel to the day's
original theme of interspecies
cooperation and Trust following the
attack the Federation would abandon
their attempt to save the Romulan people
and would also ban synthetics entirely
when Picard's doctor comes to visit him
in maps and legends he brings with him
the somber news that he suspects that a
small defect in Picard's parietal lobe
may have triggered
of several related neurological
syndromes the two of them talked about
the defect itself as though the
knowledge of it is old news which it is
the defect was first discovered by dr.
Beverly Crusher in the next-generation
series finale all good things that
episode saw Picard's skipping through
time including one thread in the distant
future when he learns that he will
eventually develop a rheumatic syndrome
a degenerative neurological condition
that can cause confusion hallucinations
and paranoia the card has crusher scan
him in his present timeline for possible
warning signs and while she finds no
traces of the syndrome she does notice a
small defect in the parietal lobe which
could but won't necessarily eventually
lead to Ihram addict syndrome while
neither Picard nor his doctor mentioned
aromatic syndrome by name and maps and
legends it's clear that this is what
Picard is worried about in all good
things we see that the future older
Picard is often second-guessed and
discounted due to his diagnosis leading
to him going against the orders of
Starfleet and calling in favors to
obtain a ship and carry out his mission
a plotline that seems like it may be
rearing its head once again when Picard
steps into the lobby of Starfleet
headquarters a voice can be heard over
the intercom paging a certain Admiral
although it's easy to dismiss this line
a simple background chatter the name
gurney has some surprising significance
in the 1984 science fiction film dune
Patrick Stewart played a character named
gurney Halleck a skilled musician and
formidable warrior although gurney
Halleck specific character traits are
not particularly relevant to Picard the
name over the pager is almost assuredly
a slight up of the hat to Stuart's
previous character making the reference
even more amusing really cared for
science fiction when Picard meets with
dr. jarate
he comes upon her paging through Isaac
Asimov's the complete robot a collection
of science fiction short stories about
what else robots as a mouse fiction
often explored ideas of sentient and
morality and robots which was also one
of the main philosophical quandary zuv
Star Trek The Next Generation and is
shaping up to be a central question of
Picard it feels
additionally significant that the
complete robot makes an appearance in an
episode that opens with a scene of
robots violently acting out
against their creators all three of the
actions shown by f8 in the opening
sequence are expressly prohibited by
Assam offs three laws of robotics
a robot may not injure a human being or
through inaction allow a human being to
come to harm
a robot must obey the orders given it by
human beings except where such orders
would conflict with the first law and a
robot must protect its own existence as
long as such protection does not
conflict with the first and second laws
looks like f8 didn't get the memo check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
Picard are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]